when I was writing leaders eat last I
got to the point where I couldn't do it
it was it was too difficult I couldn't I
couldn't organize all the information it
was just too complicated I I couldn't do
it and I'd been trying for months I
probably missed multiple deadlines and I
was sitting at my computer and I decided
that I had to give up I couldn't do it
and so I got up and went for a walk and
I was literally planning my exit I was
going through the steps was going
through the checklist of quitting I knew
that I have to give my advance back to
the publisher because technically I'm in
breach I knew that I would be humiliated
but I was preparing myself for it that I
would get over it I was also
rationalizing that it was okay to quit I
told myself there were thousands 10,000
books published every single year no one
will miss this one book and I literally
went through the steps to prepare myself
for what I had to do to quit I'm not
sure why I did this but I called a
friend of mine who at the time was in
the Air Force Special Forces and I don't
even think I said hello when he picked
up the phone I simply asked the question
what do you do when you can't complete
the mission and as is his habit he just
started telling me a story he was a
helicopter pilot and they had a mission
in Afghanistan that was a suicide
mission all the intelligence showed that
the air defenses were just too great and
none of them were gonna come out alive
and it wasn't gonna be one of those kill
Hitler missions where we're all gonna
die but we'll kill Hitler this is like
we're all gonna die and the mission will
also fail and he was preparing his
helicopter for this mission and his
wingman turned him and said what do we
do we've got wives we've got kids do we
refuse to go what do we do and my friend
turned him and I said this is what we
signed up for we go
he asked me he said is this book more or
less powerful than start with why I said
the research has impacted me greater
it's it's more powerful he says all
right I'm gonna tell you a funny story
before I met you I had become
disillusioned with the Air Force and I
was gonna quit and I found this kooky
little book called start with Y and it
completely rien spired me and I decided
to stay and I'm a better leader now than
I then I was before because of that book
and if you're saying that this book is
more powerful than the first one then we
need this book he said this is what you
signed up for you have no choice clearly
his mission was scrapped at the last
minute the underlying message of this is
what you signed up for you have no
choice wasn't a mean message the
underlying message was and I will be
here with you the underlying message was
no matter what you can call me at any
time I've got your back and that's the
important part I turned around went back
to my desk and finished writing that
book not that night I mean it took me
months but
but I never thought of quitting ever
again as soon as I knew that someone was
there someone had my someone had my back
[Music]